quelques débris de l'épave témoignent de
la violence du naufrage des policiers
récupèrent une dépouille que les vagues
ont déposé sur la plage les recherches
sont lancées pour trouver des survivants
mais la mère agitée complique les
opérations de sauvetage tant pour les
motos marines que pour les plongeurs
80 personnes ont été rescapées les
secouristes de la Croix-Rouge leur ont
fourni des couvertures avant qu'ils
n'embarquent à bord d'autobus pour leur
prochain voyage
une soixantaine de personnes ont perdu
la vie selon le dernier bilan provisoire
du nombre des enfants et un poupon âgé
de quelques mois seulement
c'est une tragédie que de voir ces
scènes déchirantes d'enfants emportés
par les eaux dit le maire de la localité
le périple en partance d'Izmir en
Turquie aurait duré de 3 à 4 jours avant
de se terminer brutalement à coupereau
en Calabres italienne le voilier en bois
surchargé ce serait fracassé sur un
rocher à bord des passagers ont raconté
qu'ils étaient environ 150 originaire
d'Afghanistan du Pakistan d'Iran et de
Somalie leur nombre pourrait même
s'élever à plus de 200 migrants selon
les pompiers ce qui laisse croire que
d'autres victimes demeurent introuvables
je prie pour les survivants et pour ceux
qui manquent à l'appel à dit le Pape
François
et de mettre un terme au départ en mer
est les députés du parti au pouvoir
le gouvernement italien de droit radical
vient d'adopter un décret controversé
pour freiner la flux migratoire en
limitant l’intervention des ONG en
Méditerranée centrale cette route
maritime la plus dangereuse au monde a
coûté la vie de plus de 20.000 migrants
depuis 2014 ici Jean-Philippe use
Radio-Canada Montréal
et j'ai forcé avec mon collègue Xavier
sabar Fournier qui a passé quelques
semaines en janvier à bord du navire de
Médecins sans frontières qui mène des
opérations pour rescaper des migrants en
Méditerranée alors Xavier donc c'est une
nouvelle tragédie qui nous rappelle que
la grille la crise migratoire dans cette
région est loin d'être terminée et qui
nous montre aussi les risques énormes
que prennent ces migrants et que vous
avez pu constater vous-même des risques
qui sont de plus en plus énormes en fait
l'exemple de ce code précis et frappant
un bateau qui part de la Turquie qui va
se rendre en Italie elle me dit non on
part de la Turquie on va vers la Grèce
parce que c'est tout juste à côté et là
dans ce cas-ci on va se rendre encore
plus loin et ça c'est lié notamment dans
des enjeux de contrôle à des enjeux de
surveillance et sera intéressant de
savoir pourquoi ces gens ont décidé de
prendre ce chemin si long plusieurs
jours en mer un bateau de pêcheurs dans
ce cas-ci un bateau en bois qui peut
renverser assez rapidement et dans ce
cas-ci il faut rajouter la mer en plus
une opération de soir pour
potentiellement éviter les contrôles
vraiment une situation de très très
risqué et un bateau qui est parti en
pleine nuit justement pour éviter les
contrôles justement c'est cette
politique de sécurité en mer
Méditerranée qui se fait du côté de la
Turquie qui se fait du côté de la Grèce
et ce qui se fait également entre la
Libye l'Italie au moins j'étais
particulièrement avec le bateau Le
Médecin sans Frontières c'est lié au
financement de l'Union européenne
l'agence frontexe également qui protège
les frontières justement en mer
Méditerranée et tout ça crée une station
où les personnes qui des ondes déjà
tellement compliquées tellement
complexes qu'on veut absolument se
rendre quelque part où on aura une
chance de survie et les gens souvent
dans les bateaux ils sont au-delà du
désespoir il se pense en fait déjà mort
et ils espèrent simplement retrouver
quelque chose de mieux rendu et donc
plus de contrôle amène ces migrants à
prendre davantage de risques et on
parlait de l'Italie dans le reportage et
de son décret qui limite les
interventions des navires humanitaires
en haut de mer et d'ailleurs l'ONU a
critiqué cette loi ou se décrit en
disant que ça allait entraîner davantage
de morts et là c'est ce à quoi on
assiste aujourd'hui c'est l'ironies du
jour se décrets qui empêchent les
multiples opérations de sauvetage en mer
avant un bateau comme 500 frontières
allaient pouvoir se déplacer ramasser
plusieurs bateaux en même temps avant de
ramener les gens vers un port sur
aujourd'hui c'est une opération en mer
c'est un seul port sûr et immédiatement
doit quitter la zone et double ironie
peut-être du sort le géo barrent de
mettre 500 frontières et justement à qui
coincé en détention administrative pour
ne pas avoir envoyé assez de
documentation lors de son dernier
sauvetage est-ce que les organisations
comme Médecin sans Frontières disent
c'est plus on passe de temps ok moi on
passe de temps en mer et potentiellement
mais des
occasions comme aujourd'hui des
situations tragiques comme aujourd'hui
pour être évité et ça c'est le bateau
sur lequel vous êtes allé justement de
celui de médecin
on croyait pouvoir ou du moins on
croyait peut-être être arrêté en raison
du fait que mais ça sans frontière a
défié ce fameux décret on a fait de
multiples opérations de sauvetage 3 dans
le cas où j'ai pu observer 237 personnes
migrantes finalement arrivées en Italie
au-delà des 69 qui était dans la
première intervention des interventions
que les images ne montent pas mais
l'odeur de l'essence qui est très très
forte
sur les bateaux pneumatiques mais c'est
le cas également probablement sur les
bateaux comme on a vu aujourd'hui sur
cette triste tragédie où les
interventions deviennent peu importe le
jour la nuit les fortes vagues ou non
des situations très très risquées pour
n'importe qui même si ça peut avoir
l'air très simple en extérieures c'est
la misère vous l'avez vu merci beaucoup
Xavier pour ce témoignage merci
[Musique]